appel après appel ils sont des centaines
à se tourner vers l'ambassade du népal
des centaines à se demander si leurs
proches sont encore en vie certains sont
même venus ici en personne parce que le
canada n'offre pas les réponses tant
souhaitée j'aurais aimé obtenir plus de
services du canada a expliqué me le tran
qui était sans nouvelles de sa conjointe
les dix personnes qui travaillent ici on
vient peu de réponses mais font tout
pour aider tout le monde a été pris de
cours explique l'ambassadeur du népal au
canada les familles dans l'attenté les
quelques ressortissants canadiens qui
ont donné signe de vie
on les pressions d'être laissés à eux
mêmes abandonné par les autorités
canadiennes l'information comme d'un
flic helmand défi voir à quel point
certains n'en ont ni à nos parents de
contacter la police népalaise
alors on se parle il ya des efforts qui
sont faibles pour avoir plus de monde à
la disposition des jeunes a le besoin
critiqué par les voyageurs et leurs
familles les ministres sont sur la
défensive
le gouvernement fait valoir que ces
ressources sont limitées les affaires
consulaires sont traités de new delhi et
les personnels de new delhi ont essayé
d'aller à katmandou mais il ya lieu une
grande tremblement de terre qui a fermé
l'aéroport pour une certaine période je
crois que les personnes raisonnables le
comprend trois agents consulaires sont
arrivés au cours des dernières heures
pour répondre aux nombreuses demandes
est depuis le gouvernement annonce que
l'avion c-17 qui est en route avec le
matériel de secours va pouvoir rapatrier
les canadiens coincés là bas mais les
institutions sont la mena pourrait
doubler d'ardeur
l'opposition elle a déjà tiré ses
conclusions
ça veut dire que le gouvernement est en
train d'appliquer un de ses
responsabilités fondamentales la
protection des citoyens
en réponse à la détresse que vivent les
népalais le canada augmente son aide aux
pays en égalant tous les dons du public
mais à travers la tragédie de l'espoir
qui abritera apprend que sa conjointe
est saine et sauve pour d'autres la
tante continue comme un vrai supplice
marque le gouvernement canadien est donc
accusée de ne pas en faire assez pour
ses ressortissants
lui dit que ses moyens sont limités s
qui ne peut pas faire plus ce qui est
certain c'est l'insee que ça soulève des
questions ce n'est pas la première fois
que ça arrive ce genre de situation le
ministre kenny est aujourd'hui n'oubliez
pas qu'à katmandou il n'ya pas
d'ambassade que c'est une région qui
relève de new delhi et que le canada
dans le fond n'a qu'un consul honoraire
au népal sur place
peut-être mais ce genre de cafouillage
est déjà arrivé dans le passé il ya déjà
eu de nombreuses critiques par exemple
lors du puissant cyclone aux philippines
en 2013
même chose après le tsunami de 2004 en
asie du sud est et à chaque fois on a
l'impression que ça donne lieu à une
gestion qui est l'aube très
bureaucratique
alors que les gens dans ce genre de
situation ont besoin d'être rapidement
informer et rassurer de savoir qu'ils
peuvent compter sur leurs gouvernements
ce que ne dit pas le gouvernement sait
qu'avant 2013 avant les compressions des
conservateurs il y avait un bureau de
coopération à katmandou une mini antenne
de la ssii qui si elle était restée
ouverte aurait pu permettre en principe
d'avoir des ressources supplémentaires
sur le terrain
peut-être merci beaucoup marc roy